let's talk about the fights saturday
night so um
do you see all of the fights yeah
yeah yeah the main card the main card
yeah the main card yeah let me ask you a
question
what happened to rey house reyes dominic
reyes yeah he seemed
so tentative yeah you know he went in
with jon jones
right i thought he won that fight i
think what happened was that when he
fought jon jones
because he he he probably did win that
fight if you ask me yeah but for the
first half of the fight he was kicking
his ass and for the second half of the
fight
he kind of got his ass kicked i've been
there myself when i used to kick box
back in the day
and when that happens you learn a lesson
about
pacing yourself ah so i think he was
pacing himself for a five-round fight
because he didn't want to get tired
again
this is the loneliest place in the world
when you're in the octagon and you've
got nowhere to hide you've got no team
to rely on
yeah you know and you've just got
another killer trying to knock your
[ __ ] head off
yeah it's a very lonely pace place so i
think he was
um yeah just pacing himself for a longer
fight and
it got clipped when you're when you're
in a fight like you're in the fourth
round
right because you've been in so many
battles right
does time does time go by quickly or
slowly so slow but it does
yeah it's the slowest ever seriously but
guess what those 60 minutes
60 seconds on the stool yeah boom flies
by just like that if you're in there and
you look at the clock
because you know you're in there and you
can have a little look at the big screen
and go oh [ __ ] 45 seconds left
oh thank [ __ ] i'm almost out of this
round oh wow guys this one's not going
well
with those 45 seconds can last like a
lifetime
a lifetime you're still in that 60
seconds boom there you go champ
[ __ ] off i just sat down yeah don't go
have you ever gone into the next room
when they said get up and go to the next
round where you
thought i'm not ready or like i i
haven't caught my breath yet
no you usually catch your breath yeah
yeah yeah
because i learned from that kickboxing
fight when i was younger ah i always
made sure i was in good shape
right that's the best weapon you could
have as a fighter of course you need all
the skills but if you
don't have the cardio and you run out of
stamina then it doesn't matter how good
you are because you're
you're screwed now let me ask you this
do you know just
without your coaches and stuff do you
know
in your head am i winning or losing yes
how
because you get a feeling every time you
get cracked in the face
you're packing him on the face too yeah
you're kind of like i feel like you have
he's hit me more than i've hit him
i don't know what day of the week it is
i've got blood pouring out of every
orifice when i look at him
he's got no blood okay so i'm just going
to go on a limb here and assume that
maybe i lost that round
you know generally i'm there generally
i'm you know kind of
yeah oh you're unconscious on the floor
you're like yeah did i lose that one
oh yeah no no you can tell yeah and
because you're constantly scoring as a
fighter oh you are
well you know because it's important
yeah because i'm when i'm watching
because i'm a huge fan i just have these
questions and you've lived it obviously
you know i mean you're a champ right
you're a champ forever in my heart
right now let me ask you something when
you when you go
five rounds and the other person's
called the winner right how does that
feel are you relieved that you get to go
home
or are you super devastated what do you
mean if you've lost yes
um i mean i never got too devastated did
i beg you got to keep it in perspective
some people do
like i remember when i used to train in
england prior to the ufc and i found
smaller events
you know and we all want to do well we
all want to make it to the ufc we ought
to make money but at the end of the day
we're choosing you know to fight in a
[ __ ] cage for a living let's be
honest right and someone's going to win
and someone's going to lose
right you know if you're man enough to
go out there and put a beating on
someone you're going to be man enough to
accept
defeat as well yeah now these couple of
[ __ ] that i was training with
crying their [ __ ] eyes out in the
locker room tom blackley is biggest
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life
what are you doing yeah getting it
together man yeah i know it matters it
matters to me
but i didn't lose so you're right so
yeah yeah no no of course but for me
um yeah i i never got too upset
yeah of course of course you lose money
and it derails your career to a certain
extra sure but at the end of the day
look at the pluses you know
yeah doing a job i love getting paid
handsomely fighting on tv
living the dream if you will depending
on what your dream is you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah listen yeah you can be
disappointed but you know
it's i have another question about
saturday um sanchez do you think you
should retire
diego yeah no i think you should fight
conor mcgregor
what was that what was that i saw that
he had released those dms
yeah and he did ask for diego he did he
has to fight diego sanchez yeah